hey this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring can we do another math theater
to help you boost your score in your
math class improve your understanding
and hopefully make learning math a lot
less stressful so what we're going to
talk about in this video is how to
stretch shift translate you know reflect
all the different types of
transformations that you can do with
parent functions so let's get right into
this video and look at some examples so
first of all you want to familiar
familiarize yourself with a lot of these
basic graphs if you recognize the basic
shape of the graph and the basic
equation that's the starting point so
let's just go through real quick this is
the square root function and it looks
like a half a parabola on its side this
is the absolute value function and it
looks like a real sharp V with the
vertex at the origin this is called the
reciprocal function because it's not ax
but 1 over X and you can see it's
actually a hyperbola it approaches the x
and y axes y equals x cubed this is the
greatest integer function it looks like
steps and then of course y equals x
squared that's our u-shaped graph our
parabola but now let's talk about
transforming these graphs so let's just
start with this one over here y equals
square root of x say for example we
wanted to graph y equals square root of
x minus 2 what do you think the 2 does
to the graph well if you said shifts
right you're right basically the way you
want to think about it is whatever
number is grouped with the X is going to
shift the graph okay in the x-direction
it's gonna affect the X or the
horizontal direction but it's the
opposite from you know what it looks
like so if it's minus 2 it actually
shifts it right positive 2 if this was
plus 2 it actually would shift left 2 so
just to show you on this graph here this
is actually going to be shifting your
graph right 1 2 and there's our graph ok
so you're with me so far let's look at
another example let's say we have y
equals absolute value of x okay say we
wanted to graph y equals x plus 3 so
what do you think the plus 3 does to the
to the graph the parent function okay if
you said shifts left 3 you're right okay
and again notice how see it's grouped
with the ax right it's grouped with the
ax if it's having the opposite effect
it's actually shifting the graph left 3
so now the vertex is over here at
negative 3 everything shifted left 3
okay let's go to the next graph y equals
1 over X what we're gonna do now is
we're going to multiply okay by 2 so
basically what i did as i said this is 2
times 1 over x what do you think the 2
does to this graph if you said a
vertical shift and that vertical shift
I'm sorry a vertical stretch meaning
you're multiplying all the Y values by 2
you're exactly right and so what would
happen is normally this graphic goes
through the point 1 1 okay you can see
if you put 1 in here that's 1 but now
it's going to be stretching it's going
to be up here at 2 same thing over here
at negative 1 it's going to be at
negative 2 so what's happening is okay
it's a vertical stretch like you pulled
on it in this direction okay now hang in
there with me I'm going to show you some
general concepts let's go to the next
one here y equals x cubed now what you
can do is you can write any of these
parent functions in a more general way
like this y equals a X minus H cubed
plus K so what we've already kind of you
know gotten familiar with here is that
the number that's group with the X is
affecting the X Direction right if it's
minus 2 its shifting right to if it's
plus 2 it's left to the one this group
of the X has the opposite effect this K
value here has the same effect if you
add 2 to the graph is going to shift it
up two if you subtract two it's going to
shift it down 2 and then this number
here in front the a is going to stretch
it vertically or if it's less than 1
like 1/2 or 1/3 it's going to compress
it ok so you're with me so far so let's
look at an example let's say we wanted
to graph y equals 1/2 x cubed plus 2 all
right so what we can see here is that
we're going to be multiplying the Y
values by 1/2 so that's a vertical
compression and we're going to be
picking up the graph and shifting it up
to now what a lot of students will do
okay and a lot of teachers are recommend
is they'll say okay we know this is
shifting up to so let's think of this
point here as our starting point so
we've taken the 2 into account what
we'll do now is we'll focus in on this
core function here and we're going to
make a table of values we're just going
to say like x and y we're going to pick
some easy values right so if I put
negative 1 that's negative 1 cubed times
1/2
negative half one would be a positive
half and 0b0 but what you're going to do
instead of graphing from the origin
you're going to treat this point like
the origin so here is zero zero here's
one 1/2 and here's negative one negative
1/2 so now the graph looks like this and
what you can see is it's been compressed
and it's been shifted up to okay let's
look at another example let's take a
look at this step function here say we
wanted to graph y equals negative ok now
again you're probably seeing the pattern
ok here we're multiplying everything by
negative one so what does that do to the
Y values it makes them the opposite so
it's reflecting over the x-axis ok so
now what will happen with this graph is
instead of the stairs going like so okay
they're going to be reflecting over the
x-axis and they're going to be going
this direction okay and these ones are
gonna be up here okay are you with me so
far ok let's look at y equals x squared
let's say we wanted to graph y equals
two x squared now the thing to pay
attention to is you see how the 2 is
grouped with the X when it's grouped
with the X it affects the X direction
but in the opposite fashion okay however
you want to say that so basically
instead of multiplying X's by two you're
actually dividing them by 2 so what
happens is just this is actually going
to be a horizontal compression okay so
basically what's going to happen here is
normally the graph goes through 0 0 1 1
but now it's going to be 1/2 1 and
negative 1/2 1 so basically what we did
is we compressed it that way and you can
see it's like being squished or hey ok
horizontally so let's look at some other
examples now I want to make a little bit
more challenging for you so let's say
for example like say for example you
took back to the square root of x
function say we wanted to graph y equals
3 square root of x plus 2 minus 1 ok so
you can see that this is actually going
to shift the graph
left - it's going to be a vertical
stretch by three and then it's going to
be shifted down one now the reason I did
it that way is because I'm following the
order of operations parentheses
exponents multiplication division
addition subtraction or you can think
about working from the inside out okay
but I think about the order of
operations so if you wanted to do this
kind of like a knob slow mole okay right
slow motion you start with the basic
graph here okay now you might say to
yourself Mario I don't know the basic
graph well just go ahead and make a
table
okay just using that core graph and pick
some values zero the square root of 0 is
0 1 is 1 4 is 2 9 is 3 these are your
basic points okay so then you can plot
those and then you say hmm I'm going to
subtract 2 from all the x-coordinate so
if I subtract 2 from these now I'll be
at negative 2 0 okay I'm going to be at
negative 1 1 okay and so now I can see
my graphs looking something like like
this shifted left 2 now I'm going to be
taking all the Y values and multiplying
by 3 this is a vertical stretch so
instead of being at you know negative 1
1 I'm going to be at negative 1 3 so
this point right here is actually going
to be moving up 1 2 3 it's going to be
like this so this is a vertical stretch
ok and then I'm going to be shifting the
whole thing minus 1 down 1 somebody
subtracting 1 from all the Y values so
each of these points is going to go down
1 down 1 and so on so now the graph
looks like that
ok now you might say that sounds like a
lot of work right so let's do it another
way so this is another way that students
and teachers will approach it they'll
say hmm let's just take the shift into
account first let's just say okay we
know this is going to shift left 2 and
down 1 right so let's just treat that
point like our starting point like our
origin so we've taken those guys into
account now all we have to do is graph
this kind of core graph or core equation
or core function but from this point not
the origin that makes a lot simpler so
you make a table again pick some easy
values that you can take the square root
of 0 1 & 4 square root of 0 0 times 3 is
0 square root of 1 is 1 times 3 is 3
square root of 4 is 2 times 3 is 6
now all we have to do is plot these
points from here so zero zero right one
up three okay and then right four three
four up six okay so you can see that
this graph is the same graph that we got
over here so depending on how your
teacher wants you to do it if they say
describe the order of transformations
you do the order of operations you say
okay it's shifting left to vertical
stretch by three and then shifting down
one but if all you have to do is graph
it I recommend doing the translation the
translation is what you're picking up
and you're shifting it that's like a
rigid transformation and then treat that
like your starting point cover up those
values that were involved in the shift
and then just graph the core function
from there so remember adding and
subtracting pick up and shift the wrath
okay multiplying and dividing stretch or
compress and the key thing to remember
is that if it's grouped with the X it
has the opposite effect so if you're
multiplying here by two you actually
divide the x-coordinates by two if you
were dividing by two say it was like
this you would actually be multiplying
X's about the X values by chuse would it
be a horizontal stretch same thing with
adding and subtracting like if you
subtract two you're going right to if
you add two you're going left two but if
it's not group with the ax like say I
put one over here that's going to shift
up one if I change it to minus one it's
going to shift down one if I put a four
in front that's gonna be a vertical
stretch okay affecting the Y values by
multiplying by four and if it's a half
it's going to be compressing it
vertically and then the last is if it's
a negative it's gonna be reflecting over
the x-axis now one last one
bonus tip right say for example it's
like this y equals negative x now see
how that negatives group with the X
values okay with the X this is affecting
the X values it's making all the X
values the opposite this is actually
going to reflect or the y-axis so it's
going to reflect like this okay whereas
if the negatives in front that's going
to affect the Y values it's going to
multiply all the Y values by negative
one and we reflected over the x-axis so
a lot of information here start by
really learning the parent functions and
then go from there
so this concludes this video subscribe
to the channel check out some my other
videos on Mars math
YouTube channel and I look forward to
helping with your math in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon